of course it's not really science in the
in the classical sense of that term
it's just whatever they want in their
political views
while they tell you to shut up sometimes
they tell you
to uh be even more intimidated than just
shutting up sometimes they threaten to
murder you which is what a nashville
city council member
just did sharon hurt who is an at-large
member of the nashville metro council
says
that if you don't wear the mask you know
wear the damn mask if you don't wear the
mask
you should be tried for murder
if mike uh jameson could be the one to
answer the question but my concern
is you know i work for an organization
that if they pass a virus
then they are tried for
uh murder or attempted murder if they
are not
told and this person
who may very well pass this
virus that's out in the air because
they're not wearing a mask
it's basically doing the same thing to
someone who
contracts it and dies from it
makes perfect sense right if you
we know from science if you don't wear
the mask
then you are spreading the virus because
the mask is not to protect you i know
early on they said it was to protect you
but then they changed their minds
the mask is to protect everyone else and
i know the masks
you know they're not that effective but
but but now maybe they are effective and
i know early on they told you don't wear
them please do not wear them now they're
telling you you have to wear them
but regardless now where we are because
of science we know
with 100 certainty that you are
murdering people
if you don't wear the mask even though
the virus has uh what 99.7
survival rates something like that at
least
very very very high 90s right even at
the most dire dire views of it
still you're murdering people is that
right is that how it works now the
science
the real science doesn't show that at
all actually
the real science shows what i have been
saying for many months now which is the
masks are extremely
dumb i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]